la plaza firdaos fue escenario de un
momento histórico un 9 de abril pero de
2003 las fuerzas estadounidenses
entraron en Bagdad la capital de Irak
como parte de su operación para
desbaratar el presunto armamento de
destrucción masiva del país árabe y que
terminó con el derrocamiento del régimen
basista una jornada de emborrable para
los ciudadanos que estuvieron en la
plaza cuando las tropas invasoras
derrumbaron la Estatua de San hussein
ese día estaba con un grupo de personas
en la plaza estábamos parados allí con
un ojo llorando y otro sonriendo un ojo
se reía porque nos deshicimos del
régimen dictatorial y el otro ojo
lloraba porque vimos la realidad de los
tanques estadounidenses en la plaza
firdaos significa que eso era ocupación
sin embargo lo que en un momento fueron
ilusiones por la caída del régimen
dictatorial de Sadam derivó el
desencanto por las consecuencias de la
ocupación estadounidense
esperábamos que la comunidad
internacional salvara al pueblo
iraquídeambre que hubiera un cambio real
a través de medios constitucionales o
legales un cambio Pacífico pero lo que
vino con la ocupación fue deliberado
colapso del Estado a través de la
disolución de las instituciones
militares la destrucción de las
instituciones gubernamentales y otras
administraciones
la toma de Bagdad la cual no encontró
grandes oposiciones para las tropas de
Estados Unidos abrió nuevos problemas en
Irak con el levantamiento de Rebeldes
militares una guerra civil sectaria y la
llegada posterior del estado islámico